when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got i can
guarantee you that bill gates didn't
start off saying i want to be the
richest man in the world
he started off saying to himself i i
really
think these computers are cool and i
want to write
cool software we started paul mitchell
with
350 each i lived in the back of my car
there's no balance life you're either
all in or you're not
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the lessons from
experienced
entrepreneurs enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be lovable with warren buffett
when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got i can
guarantee you that you'll all do fine on
money anyway i mean
uh you know think about it seven hours a
day
you know you're in a bed you've got
exactly the same mattress i've got if
you don't listen
to it the furniture mark you know i mean
so so that when we're on a parody i
can't i can't outdo you
you know in terms of my sleeping
enjoyment you can you can match it by by
buying this mattress which
we'll give you a special price on just
mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat at mcdonald's and burger king and
and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car up till about a year ago
you know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me and they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it
you know we dress more or less the same
i mean i pay more for my clothes but
they look cheap when i put them on so
we're really on we're on a parody yeah
so
so the money isn't going to be that big
a deal everybody in this country is
going to you know that
with the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean
you know so i won't i don't want i'm not
shortchanging it i'm just saying you
can't do
too much about that but you will measure
your success in life by whether by how
many
and extent whether it's the people you
want
at 70 or whatever the age may be you'll
measure by how many of them really love
you
you know in the end i mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love i mean
it doesn't work you buy sex
you can buy testimonial dinners you can
buy your name on buildings you can do
all kinds of things
but the you know the only way you get
the you know love is to be lovable
it's kind of irritating actually got a
lot of money be more fun to just write
out a check for a million dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way
and in fact it it the only way is to be
is to be lovable and you know i've got
this friend
who who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and what is it now it's uh
60 years later you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself in
determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in her mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70 if you've got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life i know
people who have a tremendous amount of
money
no one would hide their own kids
wouldn't hide them i mean
they they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know they they don't have anybody's
respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh
my friend tom murphy at campus cities tv
i mean dozens of people would hide murph
you know
all kinds of people would hide my wife
you know
that uh ben graham a lot of people would
have my dad
it would have had a number and then like
i say that i can i can tell you people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and
the kids may put up with them and hope
they don't change their will or
something but
the truth is that nobody would hide them
and if you've got a lot of people that
would hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life
rule number two make sacrifices with dan
pena
absolute a thousand percent total
commitment
and willing to make personal sacrifices
and the kids don't want to make any
sacrifices now
you know the uh putting your back to the
wall basically right correct i had no
plan b
until i was 60 years old i spent 125
of every dollar i ever made if i made a
million i spent a million 250 if i made
10 million i
spent 12 and a half million okay one
year i made 100 million
and i spent 125 million okay
at 60 my wife and i sat down and he says
uh i think we should downsize
and you know stop all that and i had a
lot of stuff okay
uh most of which i didn't use we had a
lot of houses and [ __ ] that we never
went to
uh and uh i don't believe in plan b
because if you have a plan b
i mean you'll use it what i used to say
to the kids they walk in the firm and i
would say if you're
trying to become a million dollar
producer and trying to learn my system
if you're looking at the help wanted
section right now for a part-time
any exit get the out now you have no
chance of succeeding i want you to like
put your back to the
wall make the consequences of failure so
dire and unthinkable right you give
yourself no choice
but to succeed that's like missing from
so many people these days right
they want the exit room they're half in
the half out they're the plan b
plan b right they can't be what was the
cortez campaign in the world why did
he burn the ships right why no choice
but to hack out in existence
otherwise they say the indians got
arrested out of here right
same thing goes right well the romans
did it when they came to the the uk the
second time
the uh caesar augustus burned the ships
he said we're going to conquer the
picks which were the scots uh or we're
going to die here
one or the other and uh as it turned out
they did not
conquer the scots and they built
hadrian's wall across between scotland
and england
which remnants of it are still there but
the kids don't want to
uh jack welch says it better than i
because when i hear these questions
about balanced life
i go berserk me too no there's there's
balance
there's life choices and they have
consequences jack says which i agree
that's a nice way of saying but there's
no balanced life you're either all in
or you're not also if you want to build
more confidence the sign says it can
take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email absolutely free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description
below it's important to associate with
people that are
better than yourself there's my two and
a half year old son sitting on the floor
in a bunch of clothes
and there's a note can't handle it
anymore better off with you
good luck i'm gone you want people
with a like mind and that are better
than you smarter than you more
intelligent than you to get on your bus
rule number three believe in yourself
with john paul dijoria
america still has an opportunity in
2000 i'm sorry 1980
inflation in the united states was 12
and a half percent
unemployment 10 and a half percent if
you could get a loan
if you could get a loan in 1980 and 81
your lowest
interest rate is 17
that's the primary okay and yet to wait
in line for gasoline in our and our
houses we're still in iran
worst time to ever start any business
anywhere
when we started paul mitchell we went
for half a million dollars we had a
backer
never gave us a dime the day i left
everything i did the backer didn't
nope never gave us one dime the day we
were ready the money was supposed to
come into bank of america in universal
city
my relationship wasn't going good i left
her the house the best car i took the
used car down the hill
a couple hundred dollars in my pocket
there's half a million sitting there
my partner flew it from hawaii paul
that's where he and his girlfriend lived
because he wanted some bucks he was on
his last dollars too and he's a little
older than i was
uh it never came in the money never came
and the guy said
sorry last minute change of mind gave us
all the reasons as to why
so there we were zero we started paul
mitchell
with 350 each i lived in the back of my
car
and there's a good little film to watch
it's called good
fortune how in life you could start with
little to nothing you could be homeless
you could be fired from multi-jobs which
i was by the way
and you can still succeed if you believe
in yourself
help people along the way no matter how
bad the circumstances are
rule number four focus on what you can
do with barack obama
when i see white house interns or i talk
to young people i always tell them
worry less about what you want to be
and worry more about what you want to do
because when you
when you
what when when you're more concerned
with i want to be
a congressman or i want to be a
senator or i want to be rich
then you know
some people may succeed in chasing
that uh that goal
but when they get there they don't know
what to do with it and if they don't get
there
they don't have anything to show for it
but if you're worrying about i want to
improve education in low-income
neighborhoods or i want to
deal with climate change and help save
the planet or i
then whatever you're doing in pursuit of
that goal
uh in and of itself is going to be
worthwhile it and it's going to teach
you things and it's going to
put you in a position to have an impact
and then if it turns out as a result
that you also
end up being successful uh
in in in politics uh or whatever
thing you're pursuing then uh
so much the better the most successful
business people that i know
bill gates didn't start off saying i
want to be the richest man in the world
he started off saying to himself i
really
think these computers are cool and i
want to write
cool software that's what he wanted to
do
worked out well for him um but but
so so so i think that's uh uh
that's with respect to the failure issue
if you're focused on
uh giving of yourself to accomplish
something
then even when you fail at a particular
objective
you're still succeeding in learning
about how you can
uh accomplish
those goals and rule number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is expose yourself to new things with
mark
cubit you're 21 22 23 years old
right you don't have to figure it out
right now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um paying to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start
to be exposed to different ideas and now
it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago you know it was
like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james
you know where you're always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki
um um
you know what how bad could it be i
would lose my motel 6
towel you know it was just like what
have you got to lose and yeah i
understand there's pressure from student
loans and there's a lot of conversations
we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to learn
because all these different exposures
all the different things you learn
learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juice you for for something
that you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people
quit things they're great at you know
and so
trying those things so that that's how i
advise people don't don't stress
just go out and try different things now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
turn your wounds into wisdom
you will be wounded many times in your
life you'll make mistakes
some people will call them failures but
i have learned that failure
is really god's way of saying excuse me
you're moving in the wrong direction
it's just an experience
just an experience just an
experience i remember being taken off
the air in
baltimore being told that i was no
longer be
being fit for television and that i
could not anchor the news because i used
to go out on the stories
and my own truth was even though i'm not
a weeper
i would cry for the people in the
stories and uh
which really wasn't very effective as a
news reporter to be covered in a fire
and uh crying because the people lost
their house
and it wasn't until they i was demoted
as a on-air anchor woman and
thrown into the talk show arena to get
rid of me
that i allowed my own truth to come
through and the first day i was on the
air
doing my first talk show back in 1978 it
felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so
natural to you and so i took what had
been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career
as an anchor woman in the news business
and turned it into a talk show career
that's
done okay for me
[Music]
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want to know the five lessons
you must learn before it's too late
check out the video right there next to
me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there